chinese takeout
that convenient hunger buster that can
turn up at your door within minutes in a
perfectly packaged chinese takeout box
funny thing about that chinese takeout
box it's actually american
yep
although the box's folds in style were
inspired by japanese origami the
packaging is a uniquely western
invention
in 1894 chicago-based inventor frederick
weeks wilcox patented the paper pail a
single piece of paper folded into a
leak-proof container fastened with a
wire handle
around this time california experienced
a huge influx of chinese immigrants
many came here in search of gold
bringing along their cuisine and culture
fast forward to the post-war boom every
family is moving to the idyllic suburbs
convenience is paramount and chinese
takeout starts to take off
then in the 1970s a graphic designer
added a pagoda to the side of the box
along with a faux asian thank you on top
from then on the containers became a
fixture of the chinese takeout industry
even though they have never been used in
china
you